from CNN let's talk about this exclusive
Georgia prosecutors have messages
showing Trump's team is behind voting
system breach
are you guys familiar with the story at
all no I don't know what do you think
that headline means Ian what does that
headline mean tell me what you think
Trump did
behind voting system breach it sounds
like they went into voting machines and
either stole code or observed something
they shouldn't have observed so so
messages showing Trump's team is behind
a voting system breach you're saying it
sounds like Trump's team broke into the
voting systems and stole codes do you
want to know what the real story is yeah
I'd love to account an election official
in Coffee County invited Trump's legal
teams his lawyers he'd hired to come and
inspect voting machines
and the messages they have are Trump's
lawyers saying we've been invited down
to Coffee County by one of the election
officials to to take a look at the
machines so and CNN titled it that way
yeah the word breach then is a misnomer
could even be defamatory it sounds like
they uh maybe a voting system
observation but that wouldn't get clicks
so what's happened now is
people in the state are arguing that the
election official did not have the
authority to allow Trump's lawyers to
come and inspect the the machines
therefore it was an illegal breach of
their voting systems and that Trump's
team was behind it so I saw this it was
actually Brian krasenstino who tweeted
it and he said you know here's the story
from CNN Trump's team was behind it and
I was like wow I gotta know what this is
but I tell you what every time I hear a
psychotic story about Trump being some
criminal mastermind you read a couple
paragraphs and you realize it's all fake
news and what did I find you know what
CNN the best thing CNN could do is
they wrote written invitation with
quotes
they then later say in the article
they've not actually reviewed the
substance of the invitation or the
letter itself only Communications that
confirm it was provided to Fry's Carrick
and Sullivan strickler employees kais
Carrick and Sullivan strickler are
lawyers lawyers were provided with a
quote written invitation by an election
official to go down and inspect voting
machines
incredible yeah this is the basis of his
his indictment in Georgia that's the the
whole bait not the whole basis but
they're arguing that the D.A has this
and it's a component of the charges that
are being brought against Donald Trump
it's amazing I mean it's hard not to
look at it as just complete desperation
right they want him to be guilty so
badly that they'll just make up nonsense
this is all misleading I mean you're
saying before like as he been charged or
indicted being charged means that the
D.A says that there's enough evidence to
prosecute you so the D.A really believes
there is something on Trump but now we
need the grand jury to say yes we we
believe there's enough to prosecute
right and that just doesn't happen in
fact Georgia doesn't need the grand jury
apparently they say we have enough no
matter what you say and that's kind of
insane especially the grand juries look
how they write this they write this it's
amazing on January 1st 2021 days ahead
of the January 7th voting system breach
Katherine freeze an attorney working
with Giuliani Sidney Powell and other
Trump allies shared a written invitation
they put in quotes again what does that
mean
that someone called it a written
invitation but there's maybe and this is
you go and dig through the story there
was an election official who there's two
election officials one opened the door
and let them in got in trouble and then
one provided the invitation
to examine voting systems in Coffee
County with a small group of trump
allies that group included members of
Sullivan strickler a firm hired by
Trump's attorneys to examine voting
systems in the small heavily Republican
Georgia County according to text
messages obtained by CNN that same day
fries sent a letter of invitation to
Coffee County Georgia to former NYPD
commissioner Bernie Carrick who was
working with Giuliani okay so to clarify
I don't know that they say strictly was
a firm I know that price is an attorney
when it said Fry's strickler and uh
uh and and uh what's the other name
Carrick who was working with Giuliani
blah blah blah Fry's then notified
operatives who carried out the breach
and others working directly with
Giuliani that show Trump's team had
secured written permission okay well
hold on a minute how come they over and
over again saying this article they did
an invitation and permission
yet they call it an illegal breach
you read like they said they sent an
invitation so was that in quotes like
that element of it like they said look
at this it says fries then notified
operatives who cared at the Coffee
County breach and others working
directly with Giuliani that Trump's team
had secured written permission the texts
show
CNN has not reviewed the substance of
the invitation letter itself only
Communications that confirm it was
provided to Fry's Carrick and Sullivan
strickler employees I'm assuming
Sullivan strickler is a law firm I could
be wrong but let me just double check I
don't know what firm means
but uh we'll double it Sullivan
strickler what is it legal Technology
Solutions okay so it is it is not
necessarily the employees are lawyers
one of them was a lawyer just to clarify
because I said they were lawyers in a
law firm that could be wrong all right
either way CNN is clearly lying to you
by burying the core elements of the
story and leading with Trump breached
voting systems and that quote is just
crazy like what like the written
invitation in quotes as though that's
not exactly what they say later in the
thing that they were invited and they
don't have they don't have a letter so
they can't even prove it or are they
implying that the election official who
is probably Republican if he's a heavily
Republican County was rolling out like a
written invitation like he wanted
Trump's people to be there he's giving
them preferential treatments he's he's
part of this conspiracy price I mean
that's what I think CNN is implying with
this yeah I think they're making it
sound like if me and Tim went into a
restaurant and I was like Tim please
take whatever you want off of the the
bar and he's like oh okay and I'm like I
invite you to take anything you want and
then he takes it he'd be the one one
that would get in trouble for stealing
then you maybe would say that I was
conspiring with him so I'd be the price
in that situation I think that's the
angle they're going for but if they
didn't know that it was a crime and they
were invited in by price to go check it
out then they're not on the hook if they
didn't know I mean as far as I know I
don't think so okay but this isn't
exclusive this is so thin like they use
it it's the word exclusive but they
haven't reviewed anything yeah somebody
told us but we can't confirm any of it
yeah we got some texts that said it
happened so we're gonna write a story
that happened and the way they frame it
it's like there's like a trailer out
there of a bunch of wires going in and
the Trump team are hacking into the
voting machine so like it's like if
these if these individuals it's a uh
Hampton and let's see who else was it
Kathy Latham if they were in the wrong
in letting Trump's team into this the
story should be that election officials
were in the wrong and Trump's team
mistakenly entered a presuming that the
invitation was legitimate I mean what
are you supposed to do when you have two
election officials that are like you can
come in here and do your thing you're
like okay who are you supposed to ask
especially if that's your client right
like you're like cool things this is
what we're supposed to be I'm saying
election officials from Georgia told
Trump's lawyers you're good who are the
lawyers supposed to ask if not the
election officials working at this place
I have no idea yeah the Democrats who
are in charge of the state the fake
Republicans who are in charge of the
state who hate Trump or they're supposed
to know if it's legally and Georgia is
saying these officials didn't have the
authority but has Georgia told us who
does have the authority to authorize
this or not authorize it or they're just
saying we can't say but that person was
definitely in the wrong like I don't
understand what what the game plan is
here how are you supposed to move
forward with investigations like this if
no one knows who's in charge except you
can still get in trouble
I think this was bait and the Trump Camp
fell for it they say at the bottom
Latham who also serve as a fake elector
from Georgia after the after the
election has come under scrutiny for her
role in the Coffee County breach after
surveillance video showed she allowed
unauthorized Outsiders to spend hours
examining voting systems there
so she's the one who broke the rules and
I think what they mean by allowed is
that she opened the door and people
walked in and then she wasn't partied
whatever was going on
but I think it's bait the Trump team
they had apparently had access to this
what did they find did they find
anything apparently they didn't I think
this was all them dangling the keys over
here while smacking with their other
hand ballot harvesting manipulation
through uh the executive branch of many
states this is what gives Joe Biden the
bump hatred of trump obviously and then
you had the mass bout harvesting
operation you had the ground activists
you had coveted lockdown people were
guaranteed to be locked in their houses
you told them they couldn't leave and
then when Trump's team are shocked to
find out what happened they distract all
the conservatives Republicans and
sabotage the Georgia Senate race by
screaming fraud Trump comes out screams
fraud convinces his voters not to vote
in the senate race giving the Democrats
the Senate absolutely remarkable and
then when they go down and investigate
it what do they find nothing
but this makes me remember the J some of
the January 6 uh trespassers I put in
quotes some of the people that were let
in so if a police officer says you're
allowed to come in and they open the
door for you and you walk in and they're
you're trespassing now and they arrest
you reach the capital you might say yeah
I think the cop is the one that
committed the crime in that case uh by
misleading yeah so this right I guess
that would be entrapment yeah taking
someone to commit a crime that they
would not normally commit like telling
them they're free to come in the
building and then when they do you say
now you're under arrest you're being
criminally charged and whether or not
you say come on in if you open a door I
mean if you're a police I don't know how
that works if you're a police officer at
a locked your door and you open it and
stand aside are you letting them in or
are you just neutralizing yourself and
removing yourself from the situation
like you're taking an action to open
door that is already closed like you are
going from keeping a building secure and
locked to being like I'm gonna open it
and then I don't know we'll see what
happens like of course people are going
to walk in especially if you're standing
there like yeah it's fine that this
story is open
so this this person here this what was
the name again Freight Freight something
like that they're the one that opened
the door so out of Hampton uh cat uh
Kathy Latham apparently opened the door
oh man
this is amazing it's a terrible day for
Kathy Laughlin I'm sure well I think she
already got fired but
I'll tell you man
you know I talk to people uh about stuff
like this all the time and you get a
mixed bag of responses some people say
this isn't normal and I'm like normal
they're like yeah stuff like this
happens all the time the Civil Rights
era was crazy and I'm like dude
they're arresting their political
opponents it's happening in real time
this has never happened before and
they're shielding the other one they're
like the like 100 by and stuff oh it's
so crazy like it's it's it's the Empire
it's it's a Communist Revolution like
Nixon with Watergate they you know he he
resigned but then they just pardoned him
Gerald Ford pardoned him so it wasn't
like I don't know if that's the plan
here too maybe that's the plan here they
want they want Trump out then they're
going to Pardon them and move on here's
the question Trump they've been working
too hard for this well they don't want
to be president but they don't want a
revolution yeah they wanna that's a
thing like that's they're not going to
go to if they were doing something like
this they're not gonna do go too crazy
with it because then all of a sudden the
people that they want to control are
going to be a lot harder to control so
here's what we're looking at is this a
period of political term well which
we'll get through and we'll forget we'll
forget about then it'll be listed as the
Trump era in history and there'll be
some minor conversations about it and
we'll all forget about it I don't think
so is this the beginning of a civil war
a cold Civil War or active Civil War
perhaps is this the beginning of a
revolution perhaps it really just
depends on what ends up happening
politically it could be a politically
tumultuous time which I hope for in that
Donald Trump gets elected he fires
arrests people criminal charges against
these corrupt individuals we say things
like that if Trump gets elected you know
this D.A is probably getting charged
under seditious conspiracy Trump's going
to get a D.A he's going to go in and be
like New York floor like DC Florida
Georgia these places where they were
indicting Trump you are being
investigated for a seditious conspiracy
against the United States for trying to
jail a political rival
the question I have is
what does this become
if in 100 years communist revolution
revolution is what happens
it will not say in the history books
Communist Revolution the news articles
from the day will not read of Communist
Revolution the Wikipedia entries won't
it will simply say that Trump was a
fascist who tried to steal the you know
take over the country and he was stopped
by a group of Heroes they'll make movies
about a ragtag band of dissenters who
work together to stop Trump from
stealing the election and they'll call
it the shadow campaign and then they'll
write in the history of books about how
Trump they'll have a video where Trump
is sitting at the desk and he's like I
want the system's hacked go in now and
then there's going to be some guys
breaking the door and cracking in an
election official going come on and
they're going to go up and they're going
to stick a USB into a computer and go
and go whoa that's what the biopics will
all show all the all the all the
historical error pieces or Civil War
in which case it eventually breaks out
into fighting uh disillusion uh
fracturing of government facilities
various factions fight I had a friend
ask me today he said something we we uh
when the news came out about Georgia
indicting Trump I was like this is
insane this is like Civil War era stuff
you're trying I don't even think during
the Civil War that it got as bad there
was threats of of jailing a Supreme
Court Justice I don't think I don't
think Lincoln actually did and now you
have Biden trying to uh jail Trump my
friend's life that's not gonna be a
civil war who's going to fight a bunch
of trump supporters and then I said how
many people fought in the American
Revolution
do you guys know no
as the story population it's like three
percent it may actually have been quite
a bit more than that but very very small
how many factions were there in the
Syrian Civil War there were dozen a
dozen plus different factions like
people seem to think that Civil War
means some Trump supporter will come out
file legislation and say we hereby
declare we own Civil War bang like
that's how it ever worked the crazy
thing is the conf in the in the actual
Civil War after the first battle of Bull
Run
okay so this is the crazy thing the
Battle of Fort Sumter they say this is
the start of the Civil War
only one guy died and by accident
because they didn't think there was
actually a civil war then you get the
First Battle of Bull Run what was it
Manassas or something they did not even
think there was a Civil War at that time
when we were talking about the second
fight in the Civil War and people were
picnicking and laughing and when the
fighting broke out people panicked and
fled and when the Confederacy won they
still did not believe they were in a
civil war so they refused to March on
Washington wow the Confederacy could
have just taken just one instantly by
marching into Washington after they won
the first time it's like no matter how
much was happening they did not believe
it was a Civil War I read this this I
read this academic article about when
did it become the Civil War because I
was interested with everyone talking
about what's happening in the United
States when will people actually say
we're in a Civil War I have no idea
maybe they won't because something could
change and it could become a revolution
or if it is a revolution they won't even
call it a revolution they'll say hey
they'll say justice or something like
that or Trump gets elected fires
everybody and they just say thwarted a
Communist Revolution who knows and I was
reading about how it at first it was
called the conflict between states and
uh rebellion and things like this and
then eventually after a few years I
think it was like one or two years it
was being referred to as civil war but
it's remarkable to me that they could be
shooting and killing each other and be
like but we're not in a civil war
that's crazy and then you have the story
of John Brown and Bleeding Kansas seven
years of the lead-up of the Civil War
and the people he killed and I'm like
for all we know in a hundred years
they're gonna be like
dude this like the the second Civil War
period was crazy and like we're in a
civil war now and then some dude's gonna
be alive bro we're not a Civil War come
on and then they're gonna go do you know
the story of what happened with Michael
reinel in Portland this communist with
the tattoo in his neck he walks up to a
trump supporter and just shoots him
twice in the chest
just like today we talk about John Brown
walking up to a slave owner pulling out
a gun and Blasting him in the face like
for all I know could be 10 20 30 years
or it could never happen but I'm just
saying like people never know when
they're in the conflict you can't see
the forest you're in it do you think
part of the evolution of the American
Civil War uh was different because we
were used to fighting on our own soil
whereas modern people are used to wars
being things that happen somewhere else
I mean I'm thinking in comparison like
the the time difference between the
American Civil War and or the
Revolutionary War in the Civil War
really wasn't that that great whereas we
were you know we fought in Vietnam we
fought we obviously wars in Afghanistan
but they happen elsewhere so we don't
think conflict happens on our own soil I
mean it does that I mean Civil War was
one of the bloodiest battles ever but
it's in comparison it's so far back
people like feel disassociated from it
no because they're not even we are
clearly at war with Russia and Ukraine
and even now they're like no we're not
I think it's because people don't see it
they feel like it's happening somewhere
else so it's sort of I think I I think
you just can't see the forest through
the trees you're in it so so we're
looking at any reasonable person who has
read the news and understand what's
going on knows the United States is at
war with Russia period we provided
weapons and Intel so that a Ukrainian
could blow up the flagship of the Black
Sea Fleet for Russia's Black Sea Fleet
like come on that's not Ukraine doing it
and that you say you know where I work
with Russia no Ukraine is we're just
helping them what I think it's
interesting how you said like that three
percent was in the thought the Civil War
right no a revolution a revolution but I
don't know that that's true that's what
they say well I'll Factor right now it
was so like that is such a small number
like think about all the normal
Americans that even they don't even know
about politics or even care like I know
people even just two out like an hour
away from DC they could care less and I
have no idea what I'm talking about if I
talk about something like this like we
could very much be and I I was trying to
be so bearish on the Cold War thing that
Tim was saying but honestly the more I
think about it and also I don't know
what they're gonna do the other thing
you're saying earlier about when Trump
becomes president and he starts ripping
through these institutions if he becomes
president like that's something that's a
worst case scenario for these guys like
they they quick Google search to say the
three percent thing is a myth
so let me let me but but keep talking
I'm just reading
okay well they're not damn we're wrong
about that one we'll scrub that point
we're scrubbing that point from the from
the record but the uh but think about if
you're going to be if you're married
Garland if you're any of the Chris Ray
if you're any of these guys the worst
case scenario for you is if Trump
becomes president if a republican
becomes president maybe you can maybe
cut a deal with like the Santa's or
somebody else but like Trump the Trump's
people they've been getting attacked for
four straight years they're coming for
blood like that's the one thing that
makes me worried about when you say that
we this might the last election we have
in American history at least for a while
or the last real one
between them between three and ten
percent three that's still the higher
estimate is about ten percent because
all there was a lot of militia involved
the Continental Army was about 75 000 at
the time when the U.S population was 2.5
million in that crazy and so uh a bunch
of different sources say they think the
three percent thing comes from the size
of the Continental Army compared to the
size of uh the U.S population which
makes sense but then when you actually
break it down it doesn't make sense
because women don't fight the elderly
don't fight a lot of younger people so
that could theoretically reduce the
total uh percentage of eligible Fighters
but then you take into consideration
active militia which were not registered
or continental and they say it could be
closer to about 10 percent in which case
a very very small percentage of
individuals oh it's 10 of the available
fighting force thought ten percent of
the population so like that includes
women and children like little kids too
ten percent of the population it meaning
90 100 of them are men okay so just the
available Fighters 10 of those went to
war ten percent of all of the population
fought
of that ten percent they were all
eligible Fighters
it is not that 10 of eligible Fighters
fought well then that means because that
that number will be if if so that's 30
of the population that's right kids so
let's break it in half and say the
population is 2.5 so uh let's say about
1.25 uh million men let's say that uh
400 000 are between elderly and children
uh maybe that's not maybe that's unfair
it probably would be
if uh they're having how many kids are
they having back then let's just say
five yeah at least bro five kids so then
you've got a smaller portion of elderly
we'll cut an ft 2.5 so then if we're
looking at 1.25 it's fair to say yeah
maybe 300 to let's say 500 000 because
there are a lot of children were on a
not eligible you then have 750 000
eligible fighters of that 250 000 fought
so we're looking at roughly one-third of
eligible Fighters or 10 of the total
population what I'm thinking but I'm
just throwing numbers at the top of my
head the point is this we have 300 some
odd million people in this country right
now
it takes only a and only a small amount
of people to disrupt a system in New
York so back in the day think about this
2.5 million people and 75 uh I'm sorry
and 75 000 are continental army three
percent
what how many people serve in the U.S
military service today do you want
someone to look it up real quick
Google search here and then my point is
as Ian is searching this the U.S
population is massive New York City for
instance in the in in the Metro we're
looking at 10 million in the city proper
I think it might be nine but they only
have like 40 000 cops this is a 1.3
million active duty Personnel 1.3
million as of 2022. 1.3 million
so we're talking about what point three
percent of the people of the population
of this country is active duty but it
was 10 times that during the uh the
American revolutionary period
they were during World War II they were
drafting I think three million people a
year something like that so the draft
would you could draft all that matters
is the size of institutional uh violent
forces
versus the percent of population that
are are feeling uh unrest well what I'm
thinking is it's I think when you said
cultural revolution that's what we're
looking at it's a nobody wants to come
to blows we don't want the nukes to
launch China doesn't want to invade they
don't want to trigger some sort of
Hellfire
um but they want to control the minds
they want to get people to turn on each
other and so how many people are aware
of that those are the active fighters of
the Day quotes thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time